Jason Aldean
is canceled
I don't follow a lot of popular music
I've heard Jason Aldean is a great guy
we have some mutual friends
had never listened to his music actively
I don't listen to really any pop music
actively and Jason Aldean had this song
all I heard about it was this song is
racist and controversial and awful and
terrible and so it's been pulled from
Country Music Television so I said okay
I guess I got to listen to this song
[Music]
Google
store you think it's cool like the fool
if you like
spitting his face
[Music]
try that in a small town
[Applause]
okay goes on
but you basically get the gist there's
the verse there's the chorus
and this is deeply terribly awfully
offensive
according to here's a writer for a raw
story liberal Outlet Mark Chapman I'm
sorry Matthew Chapman says I'll say this
much this song absolutely captures
everything about the American right from
the paranoid threats of violence to the
irrational fetishization of communities
where everyone acts and thinks the same
to the fact that the singer in fact grew
up in a city I guess he grew up in a
slightly larger town okay the guy's a
popular Entertainer all right I think
you can have a little artistic license
the paranoid
threats of violence
paranoid
meaning we think there are threats where
there are none after
BLM burned down the country for eight
months after I'll just speak from my own
experience after antifa tried to blow me
up in Pittsburgh like two months ago and
the FBI finally arrested them and the
doj has charged them after increasing
violence in all of our cities
and specifically increasing violence
against conservatives the irrational
fetishization of communities where
everyone thinks and acts the same first
of all
who who do you think is a bigger
promoter of homogeneity right now in
culture the left or the right
who's the one pushing that that same
rainbow flag on every Community around
the country who's the one insisting on
the exact same standards and norms and
behaviors for everyone around the
country a blanket kind of censorship for
anyone who differs from the prevailing
Orthodoxy of the day is it the left or
the right it's obviously the left that's
pushing all of that
but people are are getting wrong I think
why Jason Aldean was was censored people
think it's because he talks about
you know how to fight off the people
sucker punching people on the sidewalk
and the carjackers and the liquor store
robbers that is not
why we'll get to why in a second first
though speaking of guns
when you want to just shoot your meat
full of fire you got to check out Grill
Blazer right now go to grillblazer.com
use promo code Knolls Grill Blazers
Grill guns are designed to do everything
from lighting my cigars to lighting my
other cigars you could also use them to
expertly sear your meat Light charcoal
grills wood stoves after fireplaces just
about anything you can think of for
which you would need high power Fire
Grill Blazers offers two types of Grill
guns the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees which is the average
temperature of Phoenix Arizona in the
month of July its 30 inch flame is for
anything that you need a big bad torch
to do and then there's the cute little
SUV gun it's got a little bit of a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
carbonizing Blu-ray or other sugars and
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill using the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors so user discretion advised get
your grill gun from Grill Blazers today
let the grilling Adventures begin
rollblazer.com use promo code nulls for
15 off your order grillblazer.com
Knowles promo code notes for 15 off your
order right now head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles our friends are
Virginia cell sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging like dogs for a
restock well I've got great news just in
time for summer it's back in stock
genucel's famous Dark Spot Corrector has
not one but three Cutting Edge
ingredients goes to work fast to Target
sunspots dark spots liver spots even old
discoloration both on your face and
hands you can now enjoy your Sun Summer
Sun Beach barbecues without any
embarrassing spots geniuselle's most
popular package also features their
summer Essentials such as their
best-selling Ultra retinol moisturizer
with a powerful retinol alternative for
safe use in the sun you will be amazed
at how quickly you see the results or
you get 100 of your money back
guaranteed I love this company I love
the owner great Coptic Christian from
Egypt who left Egypt for the American
dream head on over to genucel.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the genius almost popular
package geniusell.com nulls save over 70
7-0 off janusel's most popular package
all orders will include a mystery luxury
gift ooh well supplies last
geniusell.com Knowles
Jason Aldean is censored for this song
try that in a small town people think as
they call it racist and
I don't know sexist probably and
paranoid and right-wing and all the rest
they think that he's talking about the
lyrics sucker punch somebody on a
sidewalk carjack an old lady at a red
light pull a gun on the owner of a
liquor store
that's not what he's talking about it's
pretty amazing that the libs are now
openly defending sucker punching
somebody on the sidewalk but that's not
that's not what he irritated them what
irritated them is that last
two words
small town
what they what they don't like is that
he's defending small towns
because when you defend small towns what
you're defending is
federalism subsidiarity the idea that
different communities are going to have
different Traditions from you
in within your own nation and among all
of the Nations when we can respect
people
's right to engage in certain cultural
traditions and not seek to impose all of
our culture every single aspect of our
culture everywhere else in the world
subsidiarity a very conservative very
Christian principle
also because it's those those small
towns that are are the impediments to
the libs just taking over and
controlling everything and what's the
smallest unit of the small town it's the
family so the libs constantly try to
destroy the family ultimately the libs
try to destroy a local Rule and
subsidiarity after that then the libs
take away state rights and then then the
libs even try to give away National
sovereignty so that we're just living in
some big liberal Global blob that's the
problem
has nothing to do with racism or
violence or anything like that the libs
hate the deepest theme of the song
the small town boy what a great clip
that was make sure that you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel don't miss
anything a clip an episode a two and a
half hour interview with the Q Anon
Shaman don't miss anything see you then